hi in this video I would be talking
about application of gal for us system
in Drosophila in my earlier video I
talked about how gal for us system works
in Drosophila and one of the genetic
crosses to perform this gal for us
system in Drosophila so now we would be
talking about more about its use
application in research so let's see
step by step so first thing we could do
with gal for us system is we could check
whether our gal foot driver is okay or
contaminated so here is an example here
acting 5c golfer is crossed with the
u.s. GFP so basically acting 5c is under
acting 5c golfer is under the acting 5c
promoter so this gal 4 is able to
express whatever our us construct is
throughout the body
so this acting gal4 will drive the
expression of GFP which is a reporter
here in every portion of the body so you
can see there is you can see there is a
GFP in whole body of the adult fly as
well as the whole body of the third
instar larvae of these flies and as
every cell of the body has cytoskeleton
so every cell of the body body is
actually enabled by GFP so let's talk
about another driver we can use a laugh
you know visa ban neuronal driver that
means its drive expression of us
constructs in neurons so when Allah
would Express GFP the GFP would be shown
in the brain of the fly and other neuron
spots so here you can see in the adult
fly the area marked by yellow arrow is
actually the brain so it is actually
fluorescing so the brain is actually
pressing and also in the larvae here is
the brain and brain is flourishing
intensely intensively
here are the segmental neurons which are
also labeled by GFP as in love is app
and neuronal driver similarly if we
cross gal 4 if we cross a gal 4 which is
specific to I then we would find what we
would find the eye is also pura Singh
and this type of gal 4 is GM our gal for
which we would learn in a moment now if
we cross GM our gal 4 with us GFP we
would find that the eye of the fly is
actually glowing so this means our gal 4
line is not contaminated and after doing
doing this kind of experiment if we
don't find fluorescence in the eyes of
the Drosophila that means whatever gal 4
line we have it's contaminated with
other plans now let's talk about some
more application about gal for us system
so using alpha us system we can use the
eye of Drosophila as a genetic screening
so here one side we have a GM our gal
for line and GM our is a eye specific
driver so it would drive the expression
of us construct in the eye of true
circular so now in the u.s. control we
have a particular protein say for XYZ
protein and now GM r would drive the
expression of this us construct as a
result this protein would be over
expressed in the eye and now we can see
whether these over expression causes any
difference in the eyes in the motd of
these eyes so in this compound eye of
the Drosophila you can see there are a
lot of omote ideas so this is the
control and where there is no over
expression of any other proteins and in
the right hand side in the panel B you
can see GM r is actually over expressing
protein X Y Zed and in this particular
case on expression of these particular
protein X Y Z there is a change in
morphology of the eye it appears that a
portion of the eye is actually the sales
are actually getting dead there is a
cell death in the portion of the eye so
maybe these particular protein X Y Z BZ
useful for the development of
photoreceptor neutrals we could primary
called conclude that and we can proceed
to find out the answer so this was
another type of application that we can
use another type of application is we
can use the alpha us system to do some
localization experiments on proteins so
here we have a protein protein XYZ again
and we stain the protein XYZ with a
antibody and this antibody is rhodamine
labeled so and you can see these
proteins this punctate structure in red
and the neuron here is actually this is
actually the neuromuscular Junction I am
showing so this neuron is actually
stained with cysteine string proteins
the antibody against system.string
proteins which are actually presynaptic
markers so now when we march these two
pictures we can see that this particular
red protein is present in both muscle
and neurons but particularly in the
neurons this protein is co-localize II
that means this protein is present in
neurons but here the red arrow shows
these protein is also present in the
muscles but as the yellow arrow shows
this protein is mainly presenting new
goals because the concentration of the
protein is huge in this neuromuscular
Junction part rather than the muscle
part so this type of infirmity inference
could be drawn by this experiment there
are many more experiments of the gal for
us system that we can perform so these
are a few examples
if you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up and please subscribe to my
channel and don't forget to leave your
comments below thank you